you get Freudian on me go ahead well
because because it looks to me like that
is you know when kids are little and
three and four say three to seven they
do a tremendous amount of identity play
you know they pretend they're animals
they pretend they're their parents they
they they pretend they're girls if
they're boys they pretend they're boys
if they're girls like they really do a
tremendous amount of identity play and
one of the things that's been really
puzzling me is well what happens if that
isn't if they never have an opportunity
for that because they're not engaging in
fantasy play maybe it's just delayed
till adulthood so because played it's
almost impossible to overstate the
importance of that rough-and-tumble play
and then the fantasy play that enables
you to adopt different identities and
then the negotiated games that you
talked about that enable people to
handle both both victory but even more
importantly loss that's possible that
could well be I've note that I have no